this video is sponsored by brilliant
oh crap i shouldn't have burned all that
coal oh crap i shouldn't have made us
gas dependent oh crap i certainly
shouldn't have subsidized the extraction
of further fossil fuels uh
it's too hot today last week western
europe sweltered under a record-breaking
heat wave temperatures of over 40
degrees celsius were observed in the uk
for the first time ever breaking the
previous temperature record by 1.6
degrees celsius 16 000 people were
evacuated in france due to wildfires and
as of the time of recording an estimated
1700 people died in spain and portugal
alone due to the heat this particular
heatwave was caused by an area of high
pressure settling over europe itself
caused by the jet stream which to remind
you is the fast moving river of air
about eight kilometers up over the
mid-latitudes ultimately caused by the
temperature difference between the
earth's equator and the pole and that
determines much of european weather of
course you can read more about that in
my book the jet stream typically
meanders over the mid latitudes acting
as a wavy barrier to air masses moving
around normally it changes its shape
pretty frequently but over the past week
or two it got fixed in a particular
pattern europe was trapped underneath a
meander that allowed air from north
africa to spill forth and prevented cool
air from elsewhere from coming in this
created an area of high pressure
effectively trapping air in place which
got hotter and hotter and hotter under
minimal cloud cover unable to be
dispersed or displaced which led to
record-breaking deadly temperatures but
of course the topic on everyone's lips
is was this heat wave caused by climate
it's important to distinguish between
weather and climate here weather is
what's happening in the atmosphere on a
given day while climate is the average
over several years of weather the
temperature at a given location over
several years will fluctuate something
like this caused by various natural
factors this is weather the peaks up
here being heatwave conditions and the
troughs down here being deep freezes
except what we've seen over recent years
is a temperature record that looks more
like this with day-to-day variations on
top of an upward trend what may have
passed as heatwave conditions in the
past have become more common and our
current heat waves are much hotter the
long-term average of weather the climate
has changed on this graph the recent
european heat waves are up here they
represent a natural fluctuation a
particularly hot day of the year on top
of a background warming trend caused by
human emissions of greenhouse gases into
the atmosphere and those two factors
together contribute to temperature
records being broken so yes the
magnitude of this event was made
possible by the climate crisis and we
saw this coming a paper in 2020 analyzed
the probability of temperatures greater
than 40 degrees celsius being measured
in the uk and concluded that the
probability this happening in a world
without human-caused climate change was
so small has to be zero yet is currently
something we can expect to see once
every 100 to 300 years but furthermore
that if greenhouse gas emissions are not
curbed we could see similar conditions
every three years by the year 2100 and
of course even hotter temperatures on
the particularly hot days
this is the worst pain ever
this european heat wave was made
possible by climate change and it won't
be the last in fact europe has become
something of a heatwave hotspot due to
the climate crisis a paper recently
published in nature communications
identified europe as having experienced
an increase in heat wave conditions
three to four times greater than other
places in the mid-latitudes and they
also identified the rather fascinating
reason for this increase because i may
have misled you a little earlier the jet
stream doesn't always take the form of a
single river of fast moving air
sometimes it splits into two branches
i'm seeing double here four jet streams
the paper classified three states of the
jet stream over eurasia in july and
august a single jet a double jet and a
mixed jet state they found that the
double jet state which occurred about a
third of the time was linked to heat
wave conditions and an increase in the
frequency of this double jet state was
responsible for a large amount of the
increase in heat wave conditions in
europe if looking at western europe
specifically the increased frequency of
the split jet state explained almost a
hundred percent of the increase in heat
waves so just to reiterate heat waves in
europe are becoming hotter because of
the climate crisis and more frequent
because the jet stream is splitting into
two branches more frequently
but what's causing that to happen well
the authors of the paper speculate that
land in the arctic now being so much
warmer than the sea in summer is
weakening the jet stream and causing it
to adopt this double jet state that
warming is of course due to human-caused
climate change i just want to make two
additional observations here firstly
this instability of the jet stream
causing more heat waves is kind of a
parallel to a phenomenon i made a video
about last year where changes in the jet
stream ultimately caused by changes in
the stratospheric polar vortex have led
to more frequent outbreaks of extremely
cold air in winter in the mid-latitudes
so in europe extreme heat is getting
more frequent in summer and extreme cold
is getting more frequent in winter the
temperature chart i showed you
previously has an increased mean value
now but also has an increased variance
this is a great example of how climate
change doesn't just mean everything
getting hotter all the time it means
there's more energy in the system
overall and that shows up in changes in
the dynamics and changes in the variance
of atmospheric variables like
temperature and humidity and secondly on
a practical level heat waves getting
slightly hotter and slightly more
frequent isn't actually going to change
all of that much unless you live
somewhere where the infrastructure is
kind of already in its limit like in the
uk for example railways are simply not
built to withstand temperatures greater
than 35 degrees celsius so that slight
increase in the maximum summer
temperature actually does have a
significant effect the possibility that
we need to be more concerned about isn't
a single heat wave or more generally a
single extreme event
but a cluster of them europe can deal
with a heatwave even if it's slightly
warmer than normal and its firefighting
services its water reservoirs and its
health services can just about get by
what we don't know is if they could
withstand a record-breaking heat wave
and then another one two weeks later the
increase in frequency to me is much more
concerning than the increase in
magnitude because
we have systems that have been designed
with redundancies and with reserves to
get through one extreme event at a time
we've never had to deal with multiple
extremes back to back in the same
location whether that's
category 5 hurricanes or heat waves
before
we simply don't know
if we could cope so what can we do this
splitting of the jet stream is
attributable to climate change and while
split jet heat waves and other heat wave
conditions will continue to get more
frequent this century we can limit how
much more frequent and limit the
possibility of devastating back-to-back
heat waves by bringing down our
emissions of greenhouse gases as i've
said so many times now the atmosphere is
a cumulative system that means that
anything we can do to slow the
accumulation of co2 in the atmosphere is
worth doing and the faster we can get to
net zero and stop that concentration of
co2 from increasing the better if we
don't our children will view the events
of the past few weeks as
just a regular summer
i mentioned that the temperature
difference between the earth's equator
and pole ultimately drives the jet
stream but how does that work
understanding the way the atmosphere
flows over the surface of the earth is a
study of physics and beautifully
explained in the physics of the everyday
course on brilliant who have kindly
sponsored this video brilliant is an
educational website and app that allows
you to learn skills in maths science and
computer science now you may hear
educational websites and think oh great
this is going to be like school but
you'd be wrong brilliant is all about
two things firstly making the learning
experience fun with interactive
exercises that allow you to play with a
concept and see it in action right in
front of you secondly it's all about
creating a learning environment where
mistakes are encouraged because an
environment where you're afraid to make
mistakes is an environment where you're
afraid to try and that's not an
environment conducive to learning
brilliant stresses that it's okay it's
actually productive to answer questions
and get them wrong because you learn for
next time it's a great way to complement
traditional education or pick up a new
skill as an adult whether that's
understanding statistics relativity or
neural networks brilliant is also
constantly expanding their catalogue of
courses so whether you're a beginner an
expert or anywhere in between there's an
interactive lesson to help you improve
and learn to get started for free and
try out everything brilliant has to
offer visit brilliant.org simonclark or
click the link in the description the
first 200 of you to do so will also get
20 off brilliant's annual premium
subscription with thanks to brilliant
for supporting this video thank you for
watching this video all the way to the
end i hope that you took something away
from it and that it provided some
context if you live in europe to the
sweltering experience of the past couple
of weeks if you did enjoy the video
please do share it with people that you
think may also find it interesting and
it really does help to pop a like on the
video and comment below with what you
enjoyed about it here's the recommended
viewing next and that just leads me to
say thank you again for watching i'll
see you in the next one